hey everyone how's it going my name's
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech
career and life today we're going to be
talking about
imposter syndrome i've actually already
talked about imposter syndrome as part
of a course that i did on youtube about
a year ago
but i wanted to make like a standalone
video because this is such a universal
topic
and my video quality is so much better
even just in a year and
i feel like i talk better on the camera
so today we're going to cover
what is imposter syndrome and how does
it relate to technology and software
engineering and i just want to share
my advice just like from one human being
to another from me to you as a software
engineer
yeah and before we get started i want to
say thank you to trends for sponsoring
today's video
trends is the ultimate knowledge hub
from the hustle
when you subscribe to trends you get
access to so many different leaders
in many emerging fields especially in
tech you can workshop ideas and network
with ceos entrepreneurs and investors
through trends
it's been really cool to be on the
trends platform because there's a ton of
articles
about emerging markets and trends and
analysis
about all the different things that are
happening in the business world
which all of that is inextricably tied
to tech
and while you can read a lot about these
things and other news sources
a lot of this discussion is happening on
trends they've got a ton of great
research on different markets and an
incredible community to connect with
so right now you can get your first two
weeks for just one dollar by going to
trends
dot co slash my eco for your one dollar
two week trial thank you again to trends
for sponsoring and now back to the video
so yeah let's first just level the
playing ground and talk about what
imposter syndrome is
a lot of y'all might know this already
but i think of it as like you
severely doubting your own abilities and
accomplishments
it's all those feelings of just like i
don't deserve this there's no way that i
could have gotten it
i'm not really good at what i do what if
i fail
and everybody knows that i'm just not
actually very good at what i do
all of those kinds of thoughts are
imposter syndrome i'm not going to dive
into like
more the definition or the medical terms
and psychiatric terms and stuff
but i will leave resources in the
description box down below for you to
learn more
but hopefully you're at least familiar
with the feeling of imposter shoujo
maybe you've had it maybe you've heard
of your friend having it maybe you've
seen it out in the wild you've read
about it it's a very common phenomenon
and while common it's very very
uncomfortable this is just my
interpretation but i've seen this graph
about
describing your rings of comfort zones
the middle ring
or center being your comfort zone the
place where you feel
safe and secure and each ring or zone
outside of that
is kind of a layer further from that
place of safety
and so in an ideal situation you start
from the very center
your place of comfort and you slowly
inch your way out
and you start to discover what else is
out in the world and then your actual
ring of comfort becomes bigger and
bigger and bigger because it swallows
all the other rings
as you're inching outwards towards the
world i hope this analogy is making
sense by the way
but i think imposter syndrome happens
when you're in your comfort zone but
you're kind of just like picked up
and placed in a ring that's not adjacent
to the inner circle
so you're basically in a place where
you're just like i don't know how i got
here
i don't know where i am and i'm clearly
very far away from home
like you're literally just getting
dumped there and that's the state that i
think describes why you feel like you're
a fraud because you don't see the path
that you took from the inner circle to
the outside it feels like someone just
picked you up
and put you there even if it was your
own doing and you actually traveled the
distance
maybe you don't believe that you got
there on your own or maybe you don't
trust the path or maybe you just feel
like there must have been other things
in the world that has just like picked
me up and dumped me here whatever the
case
you just feel like you're lost and that
you're an imposter that's kind of my own
interpretation of it
i noticed that i get impostor syndrome
in those specific situations
maybe it happens in other ways for
everyone else but yeah imposter syndrome
is a really really common phenomenon in
the tech industry
in surveys in and around the industry it
shows the majority of people have
experienced imposter syndrome
every event that i've talked at where i
asked people to raise their hands like
hey have you experienced imposter
syndrome
most people raise their hands which is
funny because i think every time someone
finds out that
other people are feeling this it's a
surprise to them so yeah part of this
video is to like make you feel less
alone because like trust me
i've had so much impostor syndrome and i
will talk about my own personal
experiences in a bit
we just know that it happens really
freaking often in tech and i think
a lot of people in tech experience this
at different stages of their career
in different situations because they
don't really
know how to prepare for them and it's
not because they're not skilled or
they're not supposed to be there i just
think it is
really hard to prepare for a job in tech
sometimes
because take software engineering for
example it takes a lot of skills you
have to master
a lot of different things in order to be
a great software engineer
like you need to master the art of
coding in different technologies and
programming languages and frameworks
you also need to understand how a given
code base is architected and how all of
those things come together
software engineers also need to deliver
all of that out into the wild as a high
quality product
and make sure that everybody gets a good
experience and that honestly doesn't
cover half of it because
engineers also need to understand how
the business is run and how the product
works
and in order to do that and code with
other people you have to work
collaboratively with co-workers
and different kinds of roles which
require skill in both
written communication and verbal
communication
if there's issues you need to figure out
how to debug them effectively without
freezing up like i do sometimes
i mean software engineering in a just is
about solving problems you've never
solved before and i think it's the truth
that a lot of college programs and boot
camp programs don't necessarily prepare
you completely for what's to come either
don't get me wrong though some people
just know what to do from the get-go
and certain programs are really
effective at preparing their folks for
the industry but i'd venture to say that
even those people experience imposter
syndrome too
because even if you did know what to
prepare for every single
job and role in company and product
and person that you work with are so
different from each other
that like in a lot of ways there's just
like no way to prepare for it because
you just kind of like
gotta do it and get in there get your
hands dirty and just start learning i
mean personally
every single time i've started anything
new i felt some massive imposter
syndrome whether that be
like starting a new job at a new company
or being put on a new project
or being told to work on something where
i'm just like i literally have no idea
how to do this
heck sometimes i'm the cause of my own
imposter syndrome because i put myself
in situations and i'm just like
i don't know what i'm doing and
sometimes it does get so bad but i'm
just like you know what
i'm good i'm gonna quit because i'm not
fit for this like
y'all hiring me or putting me on this
project was like a grave mistake
and i'm just gonna make it easier for
you because i cannot
do this luckily that's never actually
been seen to fruition because when i
tell people that i feel that way they're
just like
well you go everything's okay you're
fine
anyway i just want to share my own
experiences because i will say that
impostor syndrome can definitely be
managed because
for me it's gotten way more manageable
over the course of my career
and so this is where i share some of my
advice my first piece of advice is kind
of like something that i always remind
myself when i'm feeling impostor
syndrome
and it's that everyone has their own
beginning
and i tell myself that because when i'm
feeling impostory i look around at other
people and i'm like they just know
exactly what they're doing
and they've known how to do this forever
and i will never get to that level
but hey nobody is ever born with the
abilities that they have
because they all started from somewhere
everyone had a day one
of x day one of coding day one of
walking day one of eating
day one of being a manager and everybody
started from somewhere
and likely everyone was probably pretty
bad at it from the get-go
like i know i was pretty bad at walking
at the beginning but you make slow
and steady progress and then you gain
those skills over time
like you know when you first started a
code you likely wrote your first hello
world program
and that's where it all started you
didn't even know how to run the program
or what to type but you started and then
from there
you just built on top of those skills
and so knowing that everybody has a
beginning reassures me
that whatever level or state that i want
to get to
can be doable with some slow and steady
progress
the second piece of advice that i have
for managing your imposter syndrome
is to check in with someone one of the
really hard things about imposter
syndrome is that it's really easy to get
in your head and be overly critical
about yourself
because no one is stopping you from
doing so and it's really hard to be
objective about yourself like everyone's
their harshest critic and so you end up
kind of like beating yourself
up and talking yourself down all the way
down
and so one thing that i think is really
helpful is to talk to
a friend or a manager or a trusted
colleague
who understands your work or your
accomplishments
to listen to your worries because first
of all
verbalizing your fears makes them real
which i know that in and of itself is
scary but at least you're facing it
if there's one thing i've learned from
experiencing crippling anxiety sometimes
is that
you do have to face your fears because
if you keep ignoring it
and you just think that it doesn't exist
or something then it doesn't actually
address the fear
at all and once you tell that to someone
then likely your friend
trusted colleague manager whoever is
gonna hype you up and support you
so hard or even just by like verbalizing
it to like a wall
you'll realize how critical you are of
yourself
like think about if you heard a dear
friend or family member be
super critical of themselves you would
stop them right and be like yo like what
the heck are you talking about like
that's totally not true
i've seen you do x y and z like you're
gonna do this you're just
you're great you're totally fine or
whatever you would say to your friend i
don't know that's what i would say but
maybe we'd use some different words
and all this kind of leads into like my
last piece of advice is to yeah
figure out what you're afraid of and
then make a plan
usually when i'm experiencing imposter
syndrome it's just that everything is
entirely overwhelming and i can't even
see the details of what i'm afraid of
and sometimes i know exactly what i'm
afraid of and what i'm feeling impostery
about
but it's really important to i think
address that first because once you
identify it
you can address it like for instance
maybe you do a little bit
of introspection and you realize that
one of the sources of your imposter
syndrome
is that you feel like you don't know a
technology as well as other people on
your team
so sample plan maybe you get a sense of
their actual skill level first
and you can do this by just like asking
them like hey how did you get to your
skill level
in which case they might point out some
of the resources that they used or
explain like a project that they worked
on or something that really
upped their level and then you talk to
your manager and say something like
hey i want to get really good at this
technology and i feel like i'm not there
yet
i've been giving resources and types of
projects that i can work on and i was
wondering if you could help me
and then you can build a plan with your
manager like not only are you
coming up with a plan but now you have a
partner in that plan to both hold you
accountable and support you and give you
these opportunities
another example which i've definitely
experienced is that you're afraid that
you're going to get fired at your job
because you feel like you don't belong
so sample plan you talk to your manager
about this fear
you say things like i am so afraid of
getting fired because i feel like i'm
not performing well enough
and i feel like i'm not at the right
caliber as everybody else
and hopefully they reassure you they can
talk about a plan of hear the things
that you're doing well
and hear the things you're not doing
well and here are the things we can work
on together to address
all of these things and now every time
you bring that up with your manager like
hey i'm not feeling particularly hot
right now because i feel like i'm still
not performing that well
your manager can remind you hey it's
okay we've got a plan you're doing great
you're not gonna get fired i think this
is all just kind of related to like
when there's a mountain in front of you
that you have to climb
instead of focusing on how scary and big
the mountain is
just take it one step at a time put one
foot in front of the other
and next thing you know you're either
going to have climbing mountain or have
made
a good amount of progress towards the
top so yeah anytime things are scary
and big and looming just take it small
like make
small bite-sized chunks that are a lot
more manageable and then all of a sudden
it becomes a lot less scary
so yeah that's my advice for imposter
syndrome if you have any pieces of
advice
or your experiences with imposter
syndrome then leave them in the comments
down below
and if you like this kind of video then
consider subscribing i make other videos
that are related
to tech careers and software engineering
and sometimes lifestyle
things and so come join that's it for
today but i just want to say
you're not an imposter be kind to
yourself and don't judge yourself so
harshly
you have freaking got this and i believe
in you
i'll see you next time bye